so hello and welcome to another episode
of biographics I'm your interim host
Carl Smallwood and today we're talking
about Charles II the merry Monarch and
since we're talking about that Oso
British thing of a member of royalty
have a lovely cup of
tea that was very hot and burned my
tongue and I should mention that like
all our videos this one is based on an
original script submitted by a member of
our stable of writers this one being
Larry holsworth you can follow them on
their social media links if they
provided them below alongside my own but
let's get to
it on May 6 2023 Charles II's coronation
ceremony was held in London I didn't
watch it um I was asleep following this
celebration of his Ascension to the
throne which actually occurred upon the
death of Elizabeth II the preceding
September the king prominently displayed
two objects from the crown jewels The
Sovereign orb which represents the power
of the Monarch and it sat as a gift of
God and The Sovereign scepter which
represents his worldly Authority both of
which were important symbols in the role
of the Monarch and yeah just the fact
that like our King as to we like a
million pound hat and carried the holy
hand grenade from worms and a big gold
stick is endlessly hilarious to me both
the orb and the scepter had originally
been made for the coronation of King
Charles II in 1661 Charles II returned a
monarch to Britain after the period
known in British history as the internum
while however Cromwell had ruled Britain
as an alleged Republic though in truth
it had been a dictatorship Mar with
religious tolerance and persecution like
he literally banned Christmas football
and drinking three things that I hope
everyone knows are very important to
British culture so Charles II's father
oddly named Charles the first had been
convicted of treason treason like big
AES there and beheaded for his many
crimes his followers commonly called the
Cavaliers had endured persecution at
home and many fled to Europe or North
America in Exile and that's where we get
the uh King Charles Spaniel the long
hair of the Cavaliers I like that I like
that with has got a dog named after a
member of our royal family the new crown
jewels were necessary in 1661 because
cromwell's followers had melted down the
crown and ornaments worn by previous
monarchs certain that such objects would
never be needed again the restoration of
the monarchy proved otherwise and though
the Royal house has changed since the
return of the Stewarts the throne has
remained the orb and the scepter have
been displayed by every British monarch
since Charles II held them at the
culmination of a youth which have been
harrowing at best his Reign his impact
on Britain and thus the world remains
sensive here is just a small part of his
story starting of course at the
beginning so Charles II was born on May
29th 1630 in St James's Palace in the
city of Westminster London his father
was of course Charles I and his mother
was Henrietta Maria the sister of King
Louis I 13th of France Henrietta was a
Catholic as was her mother Marie deadish
and Catholicism was at the time held in
deep suspicion by br British Protestants
for its perceived loyalty to the pope
but also for its connections to the
courts of France and Spain and if you
know anything about Britain it's that we
just don't like our neighbors even other
neighbors with within Britain even other
neighbors who live in the same town if
they happen to be on the other side of
it I went to a high school and there was
another High School less than a mile
away and every day there be fist fights
between the members of those high
schools because they went to the other
High School we're are very contentious
people is what I'm saying so moving on
the connection between Charles II and
France were not merely religious though
one French King was his uncle subsequent
French Kings were cousins and Charles
like most European Royals could count
relatives among the courts throughout
Continental Europe so young Charles was
about 12 years of age when religious and
political disputes in Britain devolved
into what was known as the first English
Civil War in 1642 Britain split into two
factions deemed The royalists Who
unsurprisingly support the Royals and
were known as the Cavaliers and the
parliamentarians known as The Roundheads
for the shape of their helmets worn by
their troops and not as some say like
the really bad haircuts they had and I
say this with a bad haircut I will get
it caught soon but I I've been busy
recording these videos The Roundheads
claimed to be the true Britains while
the Cavaliers were derided as traitors
to Britain mere Servants of the Catholic
monarchs in Spain and France and
ultimately the pope by 1646 the
declining military situation of the
royalist dictated that Charles who would
until then serve with his father's
troops flee to safety he found sanctuary
in France where he lived under the
protection of his cousin Louis the 14th
then all of 8 years age his father
Charles I first surrendered to the
Scottish Presbyterian Army that
supported Cromwell in May 1646 the
following January the King was handed
over to Parliament and held under house
arrest like we had a big house it was
okay he later escaped fled to the aisle
of white and was again held in custody
at carisbrook Castle in 1647 from there
he negotiated an alliance with Scottish
leaders who promised to invade England
on his behalf Charles I first agreed to
the terms which included the
establishment of presbyterianism as the
state religion of England once the Scots
prevailed in their Invasion during the
ensuing War the second English Civil War
the English army prevailed over the
Scots adversaries following the conflict
Charles the first attempted to continue
to negotiate with all parties but
Cromwell by then had decided to
establish a military government with
himself as its head Charles the first
was placed in custody of cromwell's army
to be tried for treason during this
period his son the future child II
remained in Europe attempting to
negotiate support for his father's cause
he lived with no income other than that
from the charity of relatives and
supporters which as mentioned were Kings
and other Royals so he was doing okay he
failed to gain much support on the
continent Financial or military and he
was forced to watch helplessly from
Exile as events in England
unfolded on January 30th 1649 Charles
the first was beheaded in London the
following day they took his head
reattached it to his body embed it and
then interred it at Windsor Castle the
actor reggis Drew should we say harsh
reactions from royalists would you
believe it in Europe and in Scotland the
Covenant of parliament named Charles II
then at the hag King of Scotland England
and Ireland they then Bann the king from
entering his new dominions until he
agreed to establish presbyterianism as
the state religion in all three Charles
II at first envisioned the idea of
entering his dominions with an army
invading Scotland and removing the
parliament he had Lord montose take a
small army to the orany islands where he
was to threaten Scotland with an
invasion as means of strengthening his
negotiating position with Scottish
leaders montro decided to heroically
ignore this and invade Scotland instead
he was defeated and executed for his
troubles always listen to the guy with
the best hair at that point Charles II
agreed to Scottish terms including
Presbyterian government in all of his
domains and entered Scotland in June
1650 his agreement made popular in
Scotland but less so in England it also
led to another War the anglo-scottish
war of 1650 to 1652 it was just there
was all else to do in that war which the
primary English army called the new
Model Army was again led by Oliver
Cromwell fate did not spile on Charles
and his supporters military defeats
leding to flee causing one of the better
known Adventures of his life Charles
fled from the decisive royalist defeat
at the Battle of wer wer Worster even I
someone who lives here mispronounce um
uh British town and city name sometimes
for any Americans out there who would
like a challenge um hopefully the editor
can figure this out if we leave this in
but here's the city of um B Chester B
Chester yes it is pronounced that way
despite being spelled like that Charles
fled from the decisive royalist defeat
at the Battle of wer on September 3rd
1651 accompanied by a small party of
supporters as he flared Cromwell
announced a bounty for information as to
Charles's whereabouts as well as threats
of arrest and execution for anyone who
aided the future king during his flight
he stayed in the houses and ins of
royalist supporters many of them
Catholics several times he was forced to
dupart rapidly literally sometime just
ahead of cromwell's men searching for
him he initially attempted to reach
perceive safety among supporters was in
London he reached the white L's Priory
late on September 4th the following day
his party attempted and failed to cross
the river 7 returning to the prior he
was forced to leave and hide in a nearby
wood hiding in of all things the
branches of a nearby oak tree and while
it sounds like you know a fun story
you'd maybe tell kids like Charles II
was very fond of his time in the tree as
we're about to get to so Charles spent a
full day hiding in this tree which
became known to posterity as the Royal
Oak he later enjoyed telling this story
of his stay in the oak tree and the
story became part of the celebrations of
Royal Oak day in Britain like he loved
it he stayed in a tree following his
stay in the white ladies prior and other
safe houses and a tree Charles
eventually made it safer to Shor room
before sailing to France arriving there
on October 16th 1651 during the course
of his Escape he disguised himself as a
farmer cropped his forly long hair
adopted the language and accents
expected of a commoner he also adopted
the habit of appearing stooped in an
attempt to mask his considerably taller
of an average height for the time he
also endured several close calls he was
nonetheless recognized he was royalty
frequently escaping roundhead Soldiers
by mere moments numerous supporters he
made contact with along the way paid for
their failures to report him with their
very lives and this is just like I might
not have a chance to tell this story on
this channel so presumably there's been
a biographics about the queen like Queen
Elizabeth II she's called the queen here
um she took to wearing um very like
bright loud um single color pastel
dresses and a matching hat later in her
life and it became like a symbol of her
and the reason she did that is because
she wanted to be like picked out in
crowds CU she knew that people would
queue up for hours and days to see her
so she thought if I wear the biggest
most garish hats and dress combo
possible people pick me out of a crowd
and when she was asked like think do
people really struggle to pick you out
of a crowd your majesty you are the
queen you're literally on our money she
responded it happens more than you'd
think and she told the story of when she
she was uh walking around the place she
owns in Scotland or she did before she
died and um she was out for a walk and
met some American tourists and they were
talking to the queen being quite polite
say oh so I understand the queen lives
around here so yeah I've heard that too
like have you ever met her and the queen
thought for a moment responded no but he
has in motion to her bodyguard and the
American Tourist took a photo with her
bodyguard U which she took she held the
camera and took the photo because they
wanted to take a pict with someone who'd
been near the queen and I just love that
story like she the queen was so adorable
oh Charles arrived in Paris in late 1651
and took up residence in a luxurious
Palace at St Germaine paid for with an
allowance granted to him by his cousin
there he entered into numerous Palace
intrigues as well as attempts to gain
support against the government
established by Oliver Cromwell in
England despite familial and religious
Connections in France and the low
countries Charles was largely unable to
generate support for his restoration to
the throne his situation worsened when
both France and the Dutch Republic
entered into military alliances with
cromwell's government France's alliance
with England made his presence less than
welcome to put it diplomatically and
cromwell's agents pressured the French
to retain Charles and returning to
England cut his head off like they did
with his dad Charles turned to Spain
which included the southern Netherlands
as part of his Empire an alliance
between Charles II who styled himself as
the King of Scotland Ireland and England
and Spain took place in 1656 by the
Treaty of Brussels in 1658 Charles a
small army of royalist supporters and
Spanish troops fought at the Battle of
Dunes Against The Joint angl French army
Charles's troops were led by his brother
James until the failure at the Battle of
the Dooms Charles had planed to lead his
troops in invasion of England via
Scotland the loss of the channel ports
necessary to launch such an invasion as
well as the loss of men from the battle
put an end to those plans he remained in
Exile while his enemy Oliver Cromwell
died in the government he had managed
with an iron-handed deficiency began to
crumble under the unep guidance of his
successor Richard Cromwell in 1659
Richard resigned as Lord protector the
defacto head of government and across
Britain chaos and lawlessness reigned
the first general election in Britain in
almost two decades took place in 1660
and led to a more balanced House of
Commons roughly equally divided between
royalists and parliamentarians Charles
took advantage of this situation by
issuing the Declaration of braer on
April 4th 1660 named for the city in the
United Netherlands where Charles resided
the Declaration promised a paron for all
crimes committed during the Civil Wars
and interum religious tolerance
protection of property rights and the
return of control of the army to the
crown in return for the restoration of
the monarchy so pretty sweet deal all
things considered in truth Charles had
been residing in Brussels in the Spanish
Netherlands then still at war with
England supporters in England had
advised Charles to relocate to brada as
to appear to be no longer allied with
one of England's enemies Charles also
had no intention of extending his pardon
to those of the parliamentarians who had
supported the Reger side of his dad for
obvious reasons as for religious
tolerance Charles had never really
exhibited any dogmatism regarding any
faith and he remained largely
indifferent to the issue even during his
Reign on May 2nd 1660 parliament passed
the resolution defining the government
as king Lords and Commons Charles moved
to the ha shortly thereafter and from
there returned to England on May 25th
1660 he arrived in London on May 29th
thereafter celebrated as Oak apple day
or more abely the Royal Oak day in
Britain well wasn't that an interesting
fact or anecdote about a famous person
or persons I'm just kidding I know the
video is about Charles II we are at
least vaguely organized behind the
scenes here for anyone out there who has
seen me pop up in the occasional video
and is wondering who I am I'm Brad I
work with Carl and before anyone in the
comment section starts saying it no I do
not live in his basement I'm just
popping in today to talk to you about
the sponsor of today's video
nordvpn now I know that I'm probably
going to sound like a broken record when
I say this but the internet is not the
safest of places all it takes is for one
harmful website pausing as something
harmless or one wrong click and someone
somewhere out there will know exactly
how much pizza you just ordered for you
and your friends and also email
addresses and passwords and you know
other less important stuff if your
Online safety matters to you then you
should look into our sponsor nordvpn VPN
for those of you who don't know stands
for virtual private Network which is a
fancy way of saying when I'm online
nobody can see who I am unless I want
them to a single nordvpn accounts can
protect up to six different devices at
once so you can keep your entire
household protected hiding your IP and
online activity is a great way to stop
people from getting to you but what
about you accidentally letting them in
well that's where nordvpn's threat
protection comes in very handy threat
protection acts like a barrier between
your device and the internet it can
block trackers and malware and it can
also prevent you from visiting malicious
websites it will also scan files while
you're downloading them to see if that
file may be problematic unless it's a
video of your uncle dancing at a wedding
I'm afraid it can't do anything about
that I'm very sorry check out nordvpn
and get four months extra on a 2-year
plan by going to nordvpn.com
sbio it's risk-free with nord's 30-day
money back guarantee a big thank you to
nordvpn for sponsoring this video now
let's get back to the king and Charles
II see what I did there I compliment in
my friend let's
go despite the promises of the
Declaration of Brad one of the earliest
acts of parliament following Charles
II's return to the throne was the
indemnity and Oblivion Act of 1660 which
of course sounds perfectly reasonable
and nothing can go wrong with that
written by Edward Hyde soon to be titled
the Earl of Clarendon the Act issued a
general pardon of crimes committed
during the Civil Wars in interna though
it Exempted crimes such as murder rape
or the sexual assaults piracy and of all
things witchcraft we are talking about
like 500 years ago here remember it also
named specific individuals who would not
be considered pardoned and thus liable
for trial and yes execution after weeks
of debate 50 individuals were named in
the act as ineligible for pardon
eventually nine of them identified as
regicide were tried convicted and
executed
by hanging which sounds bad but we're
not done yet because they were taken
down just before they died and then
drawn quartered which means um having
their stomach lit open their guts pulled
out and having horse pull apart their
limbs there wasn't all else to do the
body of Oliver Cromwell on the other
hand was exed and then beheaded to see
how he liked it Richard Cromwell fled to
France leaving behind a wife he never
saw again the remainder of those named
in the indemnity and Oblivion act were
deprived of Liberty as he said so in
there by imprisonment on or deportation
their properties confiscated the lands
formerly owned by the crown were
restored to the Monarch and other
properties purchased or confiscated
during the internum were left to the
judgments of local courts and
magistrates the inter egum itself was
stricken from all records of the
monarchy with the reign of Charles II
recognized of having begun legally upon
the death of his father Charles I
Charles II's coronation took place in
Westminster on April 23rd 1661 the
following year his majesty married in an
arranged match with Katherine of branza
daughter of King John the fourth of
Portugal Katherine presented a doy which
included the city of Tangier in North
Africa seven islands in Bombay India he
also delivered some trading rights with
the Portuguese colonies as well as a
considerable sum of cash just you know
just styling on all of us with a wedding
gift like that like some islands a city
a big pile of cash and trading rights
with
Portugal Charles and Katherine had no
children during their marriage though
Katherine did suffer at least fourn
miscarriages yet Charles did not lack
progeny over the course of his lifetime
he acknowledged no fewer than 13
illegitimate children bestowing upon
many of them titles of nobility
including earldoms and dukedoms at least
two of his Mistresses were actress of no
including Nel Gwinn and Maul Davis his
favorite mistress appears to have been
Barbara vilers Who Bore him five
children um it's worth noting that she
was actually married at the time to a
guy called Roger Palmer who Charles
decides to just give two Irish peages to
in compensation for his wife's shall we
say services to the crown although
Palmer never seated himself in Lords he
did accept both titles along with the
obvious humiliation that accompanied
them Charles added to the Shame by
bestowing the titles as hereditary only
to his own children with Barbara should
Palma have children by a subsequent
marriage to another woman the titles
would not be bestowed because of his
what's the Diplomatic way to put this
Bon spree he's actually the ancestor of
several prominent persons in more recent
British history for example Prince
William the heir of parent to King
Charles III is a descendant of Charles
II through his mother Princess Diana
ironically though so is Queen Camila and
four prominent Dukes in British nobility
the Duke of St albums the Duke of
Grafton the Duke of bleck and the Duke
of Richmond all have descended from duke
DS created by Charles II for his
illegitimate Offspring and all I can
think now is just the generic like crazy
person in front of a corkboard with like
wires everywhere like where does it lead
it why does it all lead by just Charles
I second in the middle anyway Charles
was also a patron of the Arts and a
devotee of theater and music he enjoyed
the Hunts horse racing festivals and
other forms of entertainment he also
enjoyed being the center of attention
regaling visitors to his court with
Tales of his adventures during his
escapes from Cromwell and subsequent
Exile on the continent still while some
celebrated in has the merry King the guy
brought back Christmas football and
drinking for the majority of Britain
that's going to get you a lot of um like
leeway with the majority of people
others resented the extravagances of of
his courts and those of his offspring
paid for by taxes which fed the Royal
coffers the Britain that Charles II
reigned over as king underwent numerous
changes and difficulties in the areas of
religion tolerance Wars calamities and
epidemics his courts regardless of which
Royal Palace he occupied became a symbol
of self-indulgence and shall we say
moral laxity the guy had 13 illegitimate
children which most Britain at the time
didn't really care about because the
same thing happened for them and across
Britain there was a general easing of
the puritanical attitudes present under
Cromwell for example the theaters
presented more boy plays songs reflected
less restrained lyrics and poems and
Pros presented a more and I hope I can
pronounce this word correctly because
they wrote it in the script and it's a
fun word to say lenti justness which
offended some sensibilities while
delighting the less prudish and as
mentioned you know drinking Football
Christmas all those came back you
couldn't even go to church on Christmas
Day under Cromwell like what an idiot
the era marks the beginnings of the
British Global Empire bills on trade
Charles personally expanded the British
East India Company in five separate
Royal Charters he granted the company
the rights to raise its own Army and
Navy acquire territory Min money and
create treaties of alliance in areas
making it a global power in its own
right he granted similar authority to
the Hudson Bay Company in North America
giving the company control over all the
lands drained by Waters which eventually
flowed into the Hudson Bay the 1670
creation of the Hudson Bay Company LED
Charles to rename the area of what
became Canada as Rupert's
land they should still call it that the
name came from another of his cousins
Prince rert of the Ry who served as the
company's and territory's first governor
in 1665 the second Anglo Dutch War began
as English colonist and Mercantile
interest encroached on Dutch possessions
in Africa the Indies and North America
it was during this that the English
captured the Dutch colony in North
America known as New Amsterdam he was
later renamed New York in honor of
Charles's brother James the Duke of York
they didn't know that one Americans
Dutch's victories include an attack on
the river temps when the Dutch ships
destroyed a sizable amount of the
British Navy Charles responded by suing
for peace he publicly blamed the war on
his once most trusted Minister Edward
Hyde the Earl of Clarendon and charged
him with treason Clarendon for his part
fled to France where he remained in
exile for the rest of his life in 1668
Charles went to war with his cousin
Louis the 14th of France after aling
England with Sweden and the Dutch as for
that war it ended with a treaty agreed
to in 1670 in which Louie agreed to an
annual indemnity to be paid to Charles
II's Royal treasury which have been
severely depleted by Charles's military
adventures and you know all the boozing
and banging of Mistresses during all
these military and Mercantile activities
London was beset by two major disasters
the first came in the form of the Great
Plague of London in the summer of 1665
at its height in the late summer up to
7,000 people per day died of the plague
and mornings brought the call of bring
out your dead throughout the
city bring out
J for anyone Furious Charles his court
took Refuge from the horror of the
plague in Salsbury remaining out of the
city until February 1666 when cold
weather brought about decrease in the
death rate caused by the plague as for
the second disaster that occurred on
September 2nd 1666 when a small fire
began in the quaintly named pudding Lane
in one of the streets several bakeries
hence the name the preceding summer had
been dry and fat roofs and timbered
houses made up much of London proved
eminently burnable The Great Fire of
London as it came to be nown burned for
five straight days destroyed over 13,000
houses 86 churches including St Paul's
Cathedral and rendered over 200,000
people homeless surprisingly the death
count was relatively low though disputed
modern historians consider the count of
the time to have been inaccurate given
the overall destruction of the
city in his youth the tutors of the
Future King did not consider the
Sciences as a suitable subject for a
royal education while in Exile though
probably due to boredom Charles
acquainting himself with mathematics
Anatomy astronomy boty and gardening and
for the rest of his life he was a
devotee of science owning several
telescopes allowing him to observe the
stars and planets as well as Converse
knowledgeably regarding them he was also
fascinated by clock mechanisms his Royal
palaces featured scores of clock
scattered throughout and at one time up
to seven ticked away in his Royal bed
chamber which to me sounds like a
nightmare I don't know about anyone else
but I cannot stand the sound of a
ticking clock while you're trying to
sleep the only thing louder at night
than a ticking clock in a hallway um
which I discovered much to my Peril
waking up my mom when she was on nights
is when I dropped an electric toothbrush
into a sink Basin it's the loudest noise
I've ever heard in 1662 Charles granted
a royal Charter to a group of scientists
that had formed 2 years earlier
Charles's Grant established the Royal
Society though Charles never attended a
meeting of the society his members were
his frequent guests and he enjoyed
discussing new scientific discoveries
and evolving methods in the scientific
World his fascination with clock's
timekeeping and the Stars led him to
establish the Royal Observatory in
grenwich in 1675 the original building
now a museum is the site of 0 degrees of
longitude aka the prime meridian used
across the globe when calculating time
and distances on Earth The Observatory
and Royal Society together are Charles
II's most enduring Legacy and I've been
to the grenwich mood it's just a line I
was just a plaque because it's like the
equator if anyone's ever been there it's
just a line and like you know like a
little tourist trap
thing
the difficulties experienced during the
reign of Charles II were almost
uniformally blamed in one way or another
on religious differences so the
Catholics blame the war on the
Protestants and the Protestants blame
the war on the Catholics but then you've
got the episcopalians who blame the war
on the Presbyterians and the Catholics
and then you have the Protestants who
suspect that the Great Fire of London
has been started by the Catholics
deliberately working for the French and
so on and so forth until just everybody
involved went mad so religion was a
dominant force in politics as well and
Charles attempt to ease the religious
tensions with the Royal Declaration of
Indulgence in 1672 in the ACT he
cancelled penalties against Catholics
and de centers that had been enacted by
Parliament to support the Church of
England Parliament were non too pleased
and forced him to withdraw this the same
year a third Anglo Dutch War also
weakened Charles in the House of Commons
and when it became known that his Heir
James the Duke of York was a Catholic
movements began in Parliament to alter
the succession anti- Catholic
demonstrations devolved into riots and
throughout Britain Catholics were
denounced tried in kangaroo courts and
imprisoned or Worse executed in 1679 to
forgo Parliament from trying to minister
a subject to anti-catholic hysteria
Charles dissolved Parliament which is
just a thing the the crown can do like
just at any point they could just
dissolve all of Parliament and make a
new one like I I wrote a script for
today I found out about this and just
the more and more research I did like
the the powers that the queen had the
queen was the monar at the time was a
stound that she could just just just
dissolve parliament and if the new parli
that came up wasn't to their liking just
dissolve it again and do you know who
did that Charles II because four more
parliaments were formed that year and he
dissolved them all in something I think
we could all describe as a pretty big
mood Charles II became kind of annoyed
with the theater of politics and just
declared himself the absolute monarch
political enemies and religious
opponents often found themselves as
residents of the Tower of London many of
these were executed with imia pretense
of a trial all those went into exile
later in his Reign his brother James
gained considerable influence in the
court creating further eminy among
Catholics and Protestants Charles's
influence on this though was limited by
virtue of him being dead and he died
following a brief illness on February
6th 1685 likely from the effects of
renal disease he was 54 years of age
some scholars believe he converted to
Catholicism on his deathbed and others
dispute his contention he did ask his
brother Jane to provide support to his
Mistresses and even mentioned n Gwyn by
name when he uttered let not poor nelli
starve apparently his Mistresses weighed
more heavily on his mind than his faith
as they had done throughout his life he
was interred in westmin Abby in a
somewhat subdued funeral for such an
extravagant man attended by relatively
few suspicion of his conversion to
Catholicism is believed to have been the
reason for the low attendance which was
held at night on February 14th St
Valentine's Day seemingly religious
controversy follow the man to the Grave
so I hope everybody enjoyed this video I
certainly enjoyed making it and shout
outs to script or Larry holsworth for
writing this one again follow them at
the social media links below if they
provided them I've been your host Carl
Smallwood um you can find me over at fa
Fe with KL Smallwood and Wiki weekends
where we have an allog together more
relaxed style than this but nonetheless
we try and cover things of a factual
nature with a humorous um personal slant
and just yeah if you enjoyed the video
leave a like if you have any comments in
particular about my presentation and
hosting style which I'm hoping has been
refined since my first appearance on
this channel and and uh yeah subscribe
if you want to see more videos like this
and also check out the uh the sister
channels to biographics Geographics and
top 10s where I'm also acting as the
interim host and as always I'd like to
wish everybody out there the day that
they deserve
cheers